what's your name Priscilla buer you like
Elvis
Presley of course who
doesn't what are the kids listening to
these day Bobby Darren Fabian and
you what a movie Sophia
um the beauty of this movie for me is
the way that you stay with Priscilla's
perspective um and this story of this
obviously starts with her book so I'm
curious when you encountered it and what
you saw in her story uh that made for a
movie yeah I thought it was such a wild
story and to hear her perspective of
what it was like really for her as a
young girl kind of growing up in such a
um you know in Graceland and and at that
time so I was just really struck by the
human relatable aspects of her
describing her first kiss and being a
new kid at school and becoming a mother
and I was really surprised with how
relatable it is in these kind of
universal um moments that we all go
through but in this really you know uh
unique world of graceand with
Elvis so how did you think about some of
the particulars of adapting it for the
screen yeah I think we were trying to I
mean I wanted to make uh impression of
what her life was like at this moment of
of growing up and it's such a big story
so how do we condense it into
a movie I thought to frame it around her
time in graceand I knew I wanted the
story to be um Priscilla at graceand and
I knew the ending I wanted her leaving
Graceland leaving the gates and I was so
impressed that she had the strength to
to leave at that time and so it was
really important to frame it around that
and always um you know showing the you
know the emotional story of of what she
went through in her Evolution yeah so
Kaye I'll go to you in terms of
Priscilla's level of involvement with
this project you're playing an icon for
starters and then what emerged to you in
terms of a character to play and then
from there did it feel more or less
daunting to to take it
on well it's sort of the greatest gift
but also the most incredible amount of
pressure to take on in terms of knowing
that she was going to be watching the
film at the end of this journey so um um
obviously having that time with her and
getting to sit down in front of her was
such a you know a really huge gift to to
have that and and taking those little
sort of pieces from memories that she
had on the first night that they met or
um inside jokes or um just sort of
watching her relive those moments and
you know she would sort of laugh like
she was back there on that day again so
that was really um special and trying to
put it together and you know she she
gave a lot of support and uh I think she
felt like um you know Sophia was a
perfect person to tell this story Sophia
is um sort of a master at saying so much
with so little you know I think and
those moments that we hang on with with
no dialogue says so much you know the
moment of her sort of wandering out
around as a young girl in Gracin by
herself and trying to find her place in
this world or her putting on false
eyelashes right before she's about to
give birth like it was uh a challenge
but I also had the pleasure to get to
bounce off of um you know Jacob and what
he was doing so he he made my life also
a lot easier
too Jacob can you talk about finding the
human being within Elvis because I think
that's what really striking about the
characterization in this movie is it's
very subtle and it's I think a version
of him I haven't seen before both in the
way he's written and the way you play
him so what was that process like it
felt like Sophia kind of set the tone
pretty early because the emphasis was
not
on doing
a uh what's that I've forgotten the word
I didn't want to do a caricature yeah
exactly that it was it was it was never
the way it was going to go so for me it
was more interesting to kind of you know
when he gets off stage and there's
videos of him getting in the car and he
just looks exhausted and then I just
wanted to I tried to imagine what that
video would look like as he walked down
the hotel hallway and then went into his
room and all his friends left him and it
was just quiet sort of uh you know tried
to think about how did he sound because
I'm sure his voice wasn't down here all
the time CU mine isn't when I go home as
well you know so um I think it was just
about trying to to figure out like who
the the boy was behind the closed door
and Sophia kind of steered that you know
just perfectly how did you interpret
Elvis's relationship with um Priscilla
Peter ganick has this great book called
last train in Memphis and you can sort
of get the ages of him from from a baby
to the end of his life and the one thing
that's constant from the time he was
this big was everything he did was with
feeling and love and passion it wasn't
cerebral it was a it was a feeling and I
think that carries through into his
romance like when he sort of Saw
Priscilla it's it's he's just like a
child uh full of this like abundant love
and and and Force and and power you know
but it's always it always Rings true if
that makes sense everything he does is
with that
sincerity Stacy I wanted to bring you in
um you've worked with Sophia for a long
time what did your work look like and
what were some of the challenges going
into the project well we had um probably
upwards of 120 costumes for Priscilla
and there more there was more um
costumes than I think P page count maybe
I did did that math one day and um same
with with Jacob he had a lot of costumes
and I think a big part of being able to
make them and do all of that is that
they were both so patient and
collaborative and helped me to
understand um where they were and this
you know what their emotional uh place
was in the story and I had a great team
that was able to help and you know we
just were constantly churning clothes
out like every day you know she had like
five costumes every day
and Jacob had I don't know five costumes
every day was it difficult Kaye to
orient yourself given all the timelines
and how inter makes it had to be given
production well I will say like you know
um like Sophia was saying those that the
hair you know you try to you do all the
research you can you really try to map
out the arcs you know how am I going to
differentiate the ages and you know the
whole movie is the arc so you try to get
it right but then once you're on the
first day you're just like
you're running around like a chicken
with your head cut off trying to keep
your feet on the ground but um but but
really the the costumes and the hair and
the makeup were were a real anchor in um
you know i' mov differently when I had
you know the the 50s or the pett coat
and then when I was in the the massive
beehive and the the heels and the little
dresses so that was really interesting
it was it was such a essential final
piece and everything sort of clicking
together and really kept us in line like
Sophia was saying where we were in the
story and where we she was emotionally
how was it talking with Priscilla about
depicting that and did you ever have any
concerns uh in terms of artistic license
or of the weight of getting it right
it's the first time I've had that um
where I had to be torn between my my
creative expression and also the
responsibility of I'm telling someone
else's story who's alive and I want them
to feel good about it so I always had
that in mind
and um I just wanted to treat all the
characters with sensitivity and respect
and filming scenes when she was so young
it helped that Kay's in her 20s and
wasn't a teen actress and and you know
we just tried to approach it with
sensitivity and always you know say we
want to tell her story and she deserves
to have her to her story told and and do
it without judgment we shot out of order
because of the time brm we had to go by
location and so um you know Kaye would
be a teenager in the morning and then
pregnant in the afternoon and and many
many hours these guys were such good
Troopers and never complained and they
spent so many hours in hair and makeup
and and then switching into other things
not going to complain when I'm working
with Sophia yeah that that was like the
the best summer camp ever yeah there was
a lot of um movie Magic and creativity
that was really fun to be a part of I'm
curious as actors in this movie what it
was like to work with Sophia with her at
the
helm I I mean there's no one else in the
world that I would play Elvis Presley
forever uh no no
way yeah no I remember Sophia was just
like calm like water everything was so
smooth and simple and it she just
captain in the ship like you like you
could just it was like a trust fall and
you could
just fall every every single day got
easier and easier and easier she had so
much control and and Grace and um and
then you see the film and you know I sat
down and watched it for the first time
and I was like that's what it is that's
that's what you trust you know so I'm
just beside myself I'm just you know
pinching myself she really like Keeps Us
in she so much trust and freedom and
keeps us in like a bubble really
protected us along the way I'm sure
there was lots of stressful things
happening behind the scenes but we never
felt that you know there was and I think
the biggest thing we would say every day
was like does she think we're corny like
we' be like cuz if anything's corny with
Soph fear it's like you're out so we
like every day we like was that corny
did I do that corny did I look corny in
that thing I appreciate that you guys to
make sure keep the corn
out you felt it was time for her story
to be told what do you hope people take
away from it they're such an iconic
couple but I didn't barely know anything
about her and to hear her side of the
story and um and she's an important
figure and for me I I just I think
whenever you can connect with
um someone else's story and what I love
about movies is being lost in someone
else's life and we can always gain
something from you know knowing someone
else's experience and and for her story
to be told beautifully done thank you so
much thank you all for coming
[Applause]
out